en este vídeo aprenderá a revisar su
nivel de azúcar en la sangre mira el
vídeo completo antes de revisar su nivel
de azúcar en la sangre o bien si se
trata de una emergencia comienza por
comprobar su nivel de azúcar en la
sangre a medida que el vídeo le muestra
que hacer aprender a revisar su nivel de
azúcar en la sangre puede ayudarle a
tomar buenas decisiones todos los días
en lo que respecta al control de la
diabetes la revisión del azúcar en la
sangre implica pincharse el dedo con una
lanceta y realizar una prueba de sangre
con un medidor de glucosa su proveedor
de atención médica le indicará cuándo y
con qué frecuencia debe revisar el nivel
de azúcar en la sangre así como cuál es
su intervalo objetivo de azúcar en la
sangre
intenté mantener el azúcar en la sangre
dentro del intervalo objetivo
necesitará lo siguiente toallitas
humedecidas en alcohol o agua y jabón
una lanceta es decir una pequeña aguja
que se acopla el dispositivo de lanceta
tiras reactivas un medidor de glucosa en
sangre
y una hoja de registro
paso 1 lávese las manos con agua y jabón
y luego se que se las bien usa una
toalla humedecida en alcohol para
limpiar el dedo que usará para realizar
la prueba y espere a que se seque
paso 2 toma una tira reactiva del
recipiente y vuelva a colocar la tapa
para proteger las tiras asegúrese de
utilizar una tira reactiva nueva cada
vez que revise el nivel de azúcar en la
sangre
paso 3 introduzca la tira reactiva en el
medidor de glucosa
paso 4 coloca una lanceta nueva en el
dispositivo de lanceta use siempre una
lanceta nueva cada vez que revise su
nivel de azúcar en la sangre
paso 5 [ __ ] el costado de su dedo con
la lanceta para obtener una gota de
sangre si pincha el costado del dedo en
vez de la punta duele menos cambie de
dedo cada vez que realice la prueba para
evitar que se formen puntos sensibles es
posible que deba masajear suavemente o
apretar el dedo para que salga sangre
apretar el dedo con demasiada fuerza
puede dar como resultado una lectura
incorrecta la mayoría de los
dispositivos de lanceta tiene una
graduación que le permite seleccionar la
profundidad de penetración de la lanceta
en la piel se obtiene más sangre de la
que necesita disminuye la graduación
para que la lanceta no realiza un corte
tan profundo si no obtiene suficiente
sangre aumente la graduación para que la
lanceta realice un corte más profundo
paso 6 coloque la parte correcta de la
tira reactiva en la gota de sangre no en
la piel el nivel de azúcar en la sangre
se mostrará en la pantalla del medidor
paso 7 anota el número en la hoja de
registro
asegúrese de anotar el nivel de azúcar
en la sangre cada vez que realice una
revisión también use la hoja de registro
para anotar aquellas cosas que podrían
afectar el nivel de azúcar en la sangre
tales como una enfermedad ejercicio
estrés y el consumo de alimentos en una
fiesta asegúrese de realizar un
seguimiento frecuente con su médico y
lleve su hoja de registro a todas las
citas con el médico es posible que usted
y su médico deban a hablar sobre los
cambios que debe realizar a su plan de
alimentación la actividad física o los
medicamentos para la diabetes